The joe rogan experience.
My daughter Loves Bible stories.
Really?
I'm an atheist.
It's usually once upon a time before you tell them,
oh,
I know.
She knows that stories.
Okay,
yeah.
We call him the big invisible guy,
and you go old school,
Old Testament,
or do you go,
we'd do the whole thing.
Oh,
okay.
I've told you the story.
If you know the guy who's going to kill his son,
because the big invisible guy,
I say,
making them in an ice cream,
like bake him in a pie with whipped cream because you know it's,
that's how you certificate.
I don't have a knife to the throat.
I mean,
she was four,
but she loves the big invisible guy stories.
She loves the Noah one.
She loves the Adam and Eve one with the snake and the apple.
It's all,
I mean,
these stories that they've stood the test of time.
There's really some of the best stories around who was going to kill his,
his son was Cain and Abel.
Now Cain and Abel,
where the son of Adam and eve,
they were brothers and they killed each other.
Right?
I said Isaac and Abraham,
I think Isaac and I,
you know,
do we have a web?
Abraham?
Abraham was going to go,
right?
Yeah.
So I think God is asking him to kill the son for him.
You know,
as a love test.
Yeah.
Just because you know,
that's how you know,
if someone really loves you,
like,
you know,
this is why,
you give this,
um,
you give this to your,
to your wife,
you know,
like I would,
I would murder our offspring for you.
And that's the hallmark card that really helps your wife understand how much you
love her.
I'm just as an ex boyfriend murdering our right.
I would find out where your next boyfriend the beat you up.
I'll murder him.
And so,
but,
and I'm trying to tell the stories in a neutral way,
right?
Like it's,
I,
again,
I had my,
my opinions on all these stories and all that,
but she really likes the stories and she's a huge fan of Lucifer.
Whoa.
I mean,
Lucifer is the guy,
he is like her superhero,
you know,
like he is her mighty morphin power rangers.
She thinks he is just the coolest cause he's always standing up to big invisible
guy.
Right.
And because she,
for her prayer is,
you know,
everyone's standing around and say,
oh you're the best.
Oh you're the best.
Oh you're the greatest.
I love you so much.
Oh you're the best.
You know.
And so,
you know,
Lucifer gets kind of tired of that and leads the rebellion and all that.
Cause you know,
I said,
you know,
just keep saying it.
And she said,
I'm getting tired of it.
It's like no,
no,
no.
It keeps saying it because it's an eternity of saying that to the gate.
Right.
And she's like,
Oh man,
I'm really tired.
I want to sit down.
It's like now you know how Lucifer it.
Anyway,
so she's got this great,
she's just great song,
which goes basically Lucifer was raw hide.
Lucifer was right.
You know,
why the songs,
and I'm just waiting.
Cause you know,
in Canada there's some homeschooling,
which is kind of what are in schooling,
what we were doing.
But a lot of them are,
are Christians.
Right?
So we're going to at some point be around a bunch of Christian kids and she's
going to break into this song and I just,
I'm looking forward to that moment of,
I've tried to explain that maybe she's referring to a Beatles song.
I don't know how I completely bail on her at that point.
I don't know where she gets this.
And when you structure your stories,
do you use a software program to use index cards on a bulletin board?
Like how do you set up where you're moving all your pieces in your tetris game?
I used to things we do use,
I got a magnetic whiteboard in the office and write on the index cards and put
them all up with that and sometimes you know,
strings between the cards,
that kind of thing.
That's the general getting it all down the flow.
And then I use a program called scrivener,
which people can use for Mac or PC and it's basically the same thing.
It's little index cards in the computer and there's an index card that
represents a document,
each document as a chapter.
But it's great.
It's better than Microsoft word because Microsoft word,
once you get a bit past a hundred pages,
200 pages,
you're copying big chunks and moving around and it becomes a nightmare cause
you're gonna screw something up.
But Scribner,
he just grabbed this icon and drag it before this icon.
It rearranges everything.
So I've gotten pretty adept at using that a highly recommend it.
It's great for scatterbrain to keep everything flowing.
And then a lot of times it'll just be,
you know,
I get overwhelmed with the screen and everything going on and I'll just pull up
the three by five index cards and start writing everything down again,
bullet points and those put them up on the board and go through it that way.
So you like to do it digitally,
you liked to do it manually.
You like to just mix it up and constantly keep doing it in a different way that
keeps your brain moving?
Yeah.
What I find is when you get stuck there,
there's a couple of different things.
Number one,
if you just staring at that screen,
you're stuck just getting your hands involved and a pen.
And I,
you know,
like just an ink pen and paper is a tactile experiences,
different experience.
It activates different parts of your brain sometimes can like,
oh now I get it,
now I see what I was stuck on.
So that's part of it.
And other parts of it is either,
there's only so much screen real estate so you can only see so many things at
one time.
If you're really stuck,
you pull back,
right?
All these index cards,
you put it up in this,
you know,
four foot by five foot whiteboard and you kind of look at everything that can
spring your brain free at times too.
So it's largely,
it's grabbing whatever's,
if I get stuck in one area,
I'll start going to other areas and um,
when I get really overwhelmed and frustrated,
I am more comfortable slipping back into,
you know,
the eight year old version of me,
which is a little piece of paper and some notes or an next card and go back and
just ride it out until it all kind of flows onto the page.
I think Colorado,
Washington,
and eventually Arizona will be great testers to disprove all that bullshit
that's being said about Marilyn.
Do you know what they're doing though?
It's really sneaky thing.
The Colorado dispensaries,
they have dispensary's of,
they've had for a long time.
They had them back when I lived there,
but they have actual retail stores,
but they're not allowed to have bank accounts.
So they have massive amounts of cash and the government literally will not let
them put it in a federal bank.
They can't put it in a state bank.
The can't put it,
they can't put it in a bank.
They don't allow them to put their business to take the,
so they're gonna,
they're gonna have a safe somewhere and put stacks of fucking paper money.
Is this,
you gotta remember to count it or like what are you talking about?
This is the stupidest idea ever.
You,
you can make money,
but you can't put it in a bank.
Here's even worse.
You've probably heard about in Denver where they have outlets for picking up
marijuana,
but you,
there's no place legally designated to smoke it.
That's hilarious too.
Yeah.
They even have these sniff machines.
Have you ever seen him?
They put on,
they've developed these things to pick out nano particles in the air and they
put it over their nose.
Like you're watching a fucking movie.
They're sniffing to smell.
If they could smell marijuana from your home outside your home,
and if they can,
they will give you a ticket.
It's a new way to make money with a giant electric.
It looks like.
I was like a cartoon knows this guy's got like a space knows on.
Have you seen it?
No,
I haven't seen it.
There's the,
there's a thing and when they made it illegal,
half the people in Congress didn't even realize that they had made marijuana
illegal.
Look at that.
Notice the electronic nose.
It's got a compass on the end of it and shit to tell you where the smoke is
coming from.
This is so stupid.
Look at that.
That's a giant electric piggy.
That's a pig with electric piggy.
That's what that is.
And by the way,
you're a pig if that's what you do.
If you stand in front of people's houses with a fucking electronic sniffer,
not even your own nose.
You're a pig.
You trying to arrest them because they're smoking something that's now legal
inside their house,
but they left a window open.
You're a pig.
That's a pig.
Aussie disgusting.
I love technology.
Electronic fucking fake knows
the guy who made that must have been laughing like a music fuck owned.
He was probably so high when he so that patent,
he didn't even realize he fucked us.
Me and who?
He's one of us and he fucked us with his stupid electric robot knows,
but he made lots of money so he can go to Colorado,
have his own condo and smoke all day.
Imagine the Irene and manage.
If he just started his own pot selling business after he sold those things.
Imagine if he was like the bank's betting against themselves.
Hey,
we all need a cash cow.
That's the move.
That's what you do.
You develop,
you develop shit to help the cops while while profiting off weed and all eats
itself.
Yeah,
it is legal to smoke marijuana on your front porch.
And they voted last month.
10 Oh three good.
Yeah.
You could smoke on your front porch now.
Powerful Denver.
Wow.
Fuck yeah.
Denver.
Okay.